what what might it sound like now if you
give me a call when I do a call call or
even just a call to to chase anything I
always want to open my statement with
some agreeable statements and I want to
basically say some things that in their
head they're going to go yep yep I agree
with that and then I've actually got
them hooked a little bit to listen to
you know a little bit of an elevator
pitch so if you say and you level with
them look I know that you're hiring in
the space um I know that you need these
specific resources and look let's be
honest it can be a challenging to find
them because I know myself I actually
hired a project last week to do this and
it was really tough look I've got some
people that might be able to help you
with this but I just want to understand
a bit more about where you're at if you
don't say something that they agree with
psychologically they're going to go a
this is just a another sales call I'm
not that interested and just keep it
really open like have a conversation
rather than going in with a cell often
works out better I find